[Music]  don't be treated like some little wife  at home or what to be part of thing else  you'll be part of everything promise  really is a brand we have stories by  William we have music reviews by Willie  now a.m. please first not and who's  gonna write this novel my name is  Claudine I live in Montana I shall  probably not die there it's good I  believe with a base quoting in part when  our school days yes I think I had a  little something to contribute wider  phenomenon everyone's talking about it I  have a little plan to turn Claudine into  the most popular girl in France your  book will change the world  [Music]  tell me how many people in this part  using Korean Claudine right now  [Music]  people love to talk since when if you  considered scandal to be a bad thing all  those young girls you've given them  abuse really have someone I mean you  have you should own up to it  [Music]  I will continue to pursue this because I  want to  the hand holds the pen right history  you